NEWS THIS MORNING AS THE NATION
TRIES TO FIGHT THE DELTA-FUELED
COVID SURGE.
JOHNSON & JOHNSON SAYS THAT ITS
PRELIMINARY DATA SHOWED THAT
PEOPLE WHO RECEIVED BOOSTER
DOSES OF ITS ONE-SHOT COVID-19
VACCINE HAD A BIG SPIKE IN
ANTIBODIES.
CNN'S SENIOR MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT ELIZABETH COHEN
HAS BEEN LOOKING AT THE DATA
HERE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
SHOWS THAT NOT ONLY ONE VACCINE,
IF YOU GET THAT BOOSTER, YOU CAN
REALLY BOOST YOUR IMMUNITY TO
THIS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
LET'S GO OVER A LITTLE BIT WHAT
THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON VACCINE
IS.
IT'S BEEN A WHILE SINCE WE'VE
SPOKEN ABOUT IT.
SO, JOHNSON & JOHNSON HAS BEEN
CALLED THE ONE-SHOT WONDER.
YOU ONLY NEED ONE SHOT.
BUT REMEMBER, IN THEIR CLINICAL
TRIALS IT WAS 66% EFFECTIVE
AGAINST MODERATE AND SEVERE
COVID.
GOOD, BUT NOT AS GOOD AS THE
OTHER TWO VACCINES THAT AT THAT
TIME WERE MORE AROUND 95%.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THE
STUDY DID.
IT WAS A SMALL STUDY.
WHAT THEY DID WAS GIVE EVERYONE
ONE SHOT.
WAITED SIX MONTHS LATER, AND
ANTIBODIES INCREASED NINE FOLD.
IN OTHER WORDS, FROM THE ONE
SHOT, ABOUT 28 DAYS LATER,
ANTIBODIES REACHED A CERTAIN
LEVEL.
BUT WHEN THEY WAITED 28 DAYS
AFTER THE SECOND SHOT,
ANTIBODIES INCREASED NINE TIMES
WHERE THEY WERE SHORTLY AFTER
THAT FIRST SHOT.
THAT REALLY IS SAYING SOMETHING.
NOW, JIM, I'LL ADHERE THAT
ONE-SHOT WONDER, SEVERAL PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS WE TALKED TO SAID
IT DIDN'T QUITE WORK OUT THAT
WAY.
ONLY 14 MILLION AMERICANS HAVE
RECEIVED JOHNSON & JOHNSON.
COMPARE THAT SAY, TO PFIZER
WHICH IS 100 MILLION JOHNSON &
JOHNSON VACCINE TO BE USED
AROUND THE WORLD.
ONE SHOT DOESN'T NEED TO BE KEPT
AT THESE REALLY COLD
TEMPERATURES.
IT HASN'T QUITE WORKED OUT THIS
WAY.
WE'LL SEE IF THIS CHANGES
ANYTHING.
>> FOR SURE.
OPTIONS ARE GOOD.
JUST HAVE TO GET PEOPLE
VACCINATED.
>>> LET'S TALK ABOUT CHILDREN.
CASES IN CHILDREN, CAN'T BE
VACCINATED UNLESS THEY'RE 12 AND
ABOVE, OUR NOW REACHING LEVELS
WE HAVEN'T SEEN IN MONTHS.
WHERE IS THAT AND WHERE IS IT
EXPECTED TO GO?
WE'RE NOT EVEN INTO WINTERTIME.
MOST KIDS AREN'T BACK IN SCHOOL
YET.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SO THESE NUMBERS ARE REALLY
QUITE ALARMING.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED, EVEN JUST OVER THE
COURSE OF THE SUMMER.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE WEEK
OF AUGUST 12, THERE WERE ABOUT
180,000 NEW CASES AMONG
CHILDREN.
COMPARE THAT TO THE WEEK OF JULY
15th.
NOT EVEN A MONTH BEFORE.
ONLY 38,000 NEW CASES IN THAT
WEEK.
THAT REALLY TELLS YOU SOMETHING.
NOW, SOME PEOPLE MIGHT LOOK AT
THESE NUMBERS AND SAY, OH, DOES
IT REALLY MATTER?
CHILDREN, YOU KNOW, A TINY
PERCENTAGE END UP IN THE
HOSPITAL OR END UP DYING.
THAT IS TRUE.
BUT THE MORE CASES YOU HAVE, THE
MORE HOSPITALIZED CHILDREN
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
THE MORE DEAD CHILDREN YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE.
AND AS DR. ROCHELLE WALENSKY THE
HEAD OF THE CDC PUT IT TO A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, CHILDREN ARE
NOT SUPPOSED TO DIE.
YOU SHOULDN'T EVEN HAVE ONE
CHILD DEAD FROM THIS VIRUS.
SO IT IS WORTH TRYING TO GET
THESE NUMBERS DOWN.
>> ELIZABETH COHEN, THANKS VERY
MUCH.
LET'S SPEAK MORE WITH DR. CARLOS
DEL RIO, EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATE
DEAN OF EMORYIE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE GRADY HEALTH SYSTEM.
DR. DEL RIO, ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE
YOU ON.
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING HERE ABOUT CHILDREN.
LISTEN, I'VE GOT TWO KIDS BELOW
THE AGE OF 12, NOT VACCINATED.
I DON'T WANT THEM TO GET
INFECTED CERTAINLY, BUT I DO
LOOK AT THE DATA AND I KNOW IT'S
A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
CHILDREN WHO GET SEVERE DISEASE.
HOW SHOULD PARENTS VIEW THIS?
SHOULD THEY VIEW THIS AS A
MOMENT TO TAKE REASONABLE
PRECAUTIONS, WEAR A MASK IN
SCHOOL, FOR INSTANCE, WATCH FOR
NEWS OF APPROVAL FOR A VACCINE
FOR 12 AND UNDER?
OR DO THEY NEED TO LOOK AT THIS,
IN YOUR VIEW, MORE -- WITH MORE
CONCERN?
>> JIM, I WOULD THINK ABOUT IT
THE WAY YOU WOULD THINK, FOR
EXAMPLE, ABOUT LETTING YOUR KIDS
WALK TO SCHOOL OR, YOU KNOW,
DRIVE THEIR BIKE TO SKOOM.
YOU WANT TO ALLOW THEM TO DO
THAT, BUT YOU WANT TO DO IT IN
THE SAFEST POSSIBLE WAY.
YOU WANT TO PUT A HELMET ON
THEM, WHEN TO CROSS THE STREET,
ET CETERA.
I WOULD SAY THE SAME WAY.
THE BEST WAY TO PROTECT CHILDREN
NOT CANDIDATES TO BE VACCINATED,
12 AND UNDER, ARE TO DO TWO
THINGS.
ONE, HAVE ALL THE ADULTS AROUND
THEM VACCINATED.
ANYONE OVER THE AGE OF 16 SHOULD
BE VACCINATED.
AND NUMBER TWO, WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY WHO IS WITH THEM
AND THOSE KIDS ARE ALSO WEARING
A MASK.
AND THAT'S WHY, YOU KNOW,
BAFFLES ME THAT WE HAVE HAD SO
MANY CONTROVERSY ABOUT MASKING
IN SCHOOL.
IF I WAS SENDING MY KIDS THAT
AGE TO SCHOOL, I WOULD WANT THEM
MASK AND ALSO ASK THE TEACHER,
ANYBODY WHO IS WITH THEM ALSO
MASK.
REDUCE THE RISK TO THE KIDS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
>> I'M WITH YOU.
THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE EITHER FOR
POLITICS OR NOT UNDERSTANDING
THE SCIENCE OR REFUSING TO MASK
OR GET VACCINATED THEMSELVES,
PUTTING KIDS WHO CAN'T BE
VACCINATED AT RISK JUST BLOWS MY
MIND.
>>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE NEWS
ABOUT THE J&J BOOSTER BECAUSE
THE J&J SHOT, IT'S A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE MANY HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOSES NOW PUT
OUT.
PFIZER AND MODERNA IN THIS
COUNTRY FAR IN THE LEAD.
THAT'S IT, IT'S IMPORTANT.
IT'S ONE SHOT.
SHOULD THIS GIVE US SOME
ENCOURAGEMENT HERE?
BECAUSE NOW YOU HAVE ANOTHER
OPTION WITH THE BOOSTER THAT
RELIABLY ACCORDING TO THE DATA
FIGHTS BACK AGAINST THE DELTA
VARIANT.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, JIM, LET ME
START BY SAYING WE HAVE NO
CLINICAL EVIDENCE THAT YOU'RE
SEEING MORE FAILURES WITH JUST
J&J THAN WITH THE OTHER
VACCINES.
SO I THINK WE'RE COMING TO A
PREMATURE CONCLUSION.
WE HAVE NO DATA SAYING THOSE WHO
GOT J&J ARE GETTING HOSPITALIZED
MORE THAN THOSE WHO GOT PFIZER
OR MODERNA.
THE PROTECTION IS ABOUT THE
SAME.
I'M NOT VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT.
WHAT WE SEE IN THE STUDIES, AN
INCREASE IN ANTIBODIES, WE NEED
A STUDY THAT TELLS US IT
TRANSLATES TO BETTER PROTECTION
FROM INFECTION AND DECREASE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATH.
AND THE CLINICAL OUTCOMES DATA
SIMPLY NOT THERE.
SO THIS IS ENCOURAGING NEWS, BUT
AGAIN, I WOULD BE VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT MAKING THE LEAP OF FAITH
SAYING BECAUSE OF THIS THEREFORE
THAT MEANS IT'S PROTECTIVE.
>> FAIR ENOUGH.
IT'S A SMART POINT.
BY THE WAY, HAVING OPTIONS IS
GOOD, NO QUESTION.
>>> FINAL QUESTION, IF I CAN.
WE HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNING DATA
ABOUT WHAT THE DELTA VARIANT IS
DOING, PARTICULARLY IN STATES
WITH LOW VACCINATION RATES.
WE HAVE SOME BETTER NEWS,
THOUGH, RIGHT, WHERE WE SEE THE
DAILY AVERAGE OF VACCINATIONS
TWEAKING UP, THAT KIND OF THING.
WE SEE A LOT OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
REQUIRING MASKS AS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE IS.
ARE YOU SEEING ANY, ANY DATA
THAT GIVES YOU AN INDICATION
THAT THE COUNTRY IS RESPONDING
TO THE DELTA SURGE IN A WAY THAT
SHOULD ENCOURAGE US?
I'M NOT SAYING THE THREAT IS
GONE.
YOU GET MY POINT, THOUGH, HERE.
ARE THERE SIGNS THAT WE'RE
GETTING A HANDLE ON THIS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WITHOUT DOUBT
WE'RE SEEING MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE VACCINATED.
BUT AGAIN, THE PEOPLE VACCINATED
TODAY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
PROTECTED UNTIL SIX WEEKS FROM
NOW.
SO IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME.
BUT I THINK PEOPLE ARE TAKING
DE
DELTA SERIOUSLY.
I THINK THEY'RE REALIZING THIS
IS SOMETHING THEY NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
I'M HOPING AS A RESULT OF THAT
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE A
FLATTENING OF THE CURVE, DELTA
INCREASES IN SOME PLACES.
EVEN FLORIDA IS BEGINNING TO SEE
A LITTLE BIT OF FLATTENING WHICH
MAY BE ENCOURAGING NEWS.
THE REALITY IS DELTA IS BETTER.
I WANT TO REASSURE IF YOU'VE
BEEN VACCINATED, YOU REALLY ARE
IN GOOD SHAPE EVEN WITH THE
LOWER PROTECTION AGAINST
INFECTION FROM DELTA.
THERE MAY BE BREAKTHROUGH CASES
BUT YOU'RE UNLIKELY TO BE
HOSPITALIZED OR DEAD.
THE PROBLEM IS PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT VACCINATED.
IF I WAS NOT VACCINATED, I WOULD
REALLY BE SCARED ABOUT THIS
STRAIN.
THIS IS REALLY HIGHLY
TRANSMISSIBLE AND YOU CAN GET --
YOU CAN END UP BEING VERY SICK.
I CAN TELL YOU, WE HAVE OUR
HOSPITALS FULL OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN VACCINATED WHO ARE
IN THE I.C.U., WHO ARE ON
VENTILATORS.
AND THIS IS REALLY -- THIS IS
THE TRAGEDY, RIGHT.
>> THE VAST -- THE DATA SHOWS
THE VAST, VASTst VAST MAJORITY
OF FOLKS GETTING SICK